what's going on there citizens the
reject nation we are going to continue
brooklyn nine-nine season three
episode what john it's episode 19 and
it's called terry kitties but before we
do that i want to give another thank you
to today's sponsor which is storyblocks
wanted to run what we normally say about
storyblocks at the beginning of this
video because as we've been working with
them and i've been working on some other
stuff with our editors storyblocks has
actually really come in handy so if
you're an aspiring filmmaker you want to
create some youtube videos or something
storyblocks has been an essential part
of the process thus far so please give
them a listen and then we'll move on to
the reaction
thank you to storyblocks for sponsoring
this video being the cinematic artisans
we obviously are we are always in search
of ways to make our videos look better
faster and most of all for cheap cheap
is good and if you're a content creator
or filmmaker or anything in between
you're probably in a similar position
it's tough to get your content looking
as good as it can be without breaking
the bank or burning yourself out in the
process which is why i heavily encourage
you guys to check out what storyblocks
has to offer cheap is good do you feel
like this is their way of telling us
that the videos could be looking better
yes whether it's the credibility of an
exotic establishing shot the soothing
comfort of the perfect music bed or just
the satisfaction of increasing your
graphical capability storybox has an
incredibly inclusive and diverse library
of faces places sounds titles
transitions filters and effects and more
over a million assets royalty free and
available for personal and commercial
use with your membership sounds so
affordable this is quite affordable they
have multiple subscription levels to
suit your exact needs whether you're an
independent indie solo creator or a
whole team so if you want to learn more
head on down to our link in the
description box and get started that's
at storyblocks.com
rejects now back to the video
someone had a good time in paris oh
kevin and i shared a perfect week
together i feel like i'm floating on a i
wonder why people don't just break into
song more often i've been asking you for
months if i could answer the phone like
[Laughter]
give it a whirl
he will say yes to anything right now i
would like a police source and i'd like
terry to be riding it almost constantly
i'd like an hr person to remind everyone
about workplace boundaries the japanese
make toilet seats would squirt a heated
jet of water right up your i'm gonna
stop you right there bud [ __ ]
bum
well maybe it's not that bad maybe they
didn't upset him what did you do what'd
you say nothing we just said welcome
back and laughed with him about all the
weight he gained in france
why is everyone just standing around get
back to work what i gained three pounds
in paris three pounds oh
what a fat ass what a
slob
i haven't gained three pounds in the
last couple weeks i'm as skinny as a
stick
that's whoa where'd you go
oh there you are
i had to look from the front prop prop
comedy but seriously what's in the box
the worst thing in the world
shut up stupid what the hell terry it
was 1995.
i just made detectives i was really
excited about my first day at the 6'5
it's the flat top hi i'm terry which
desk is mine solve a case then you get a
desk they were like that about a lot of
stuff so i picked the biggest one i
could find after a month i found my
suspect
dimitri kuzco an ex-acrobat with a
criminal wreck good cat
hey what
i may have gotten a little flustered
look he's got a cat he trained the cat
to do the robbery that's why they call
them cat burgers
oh
now they sent me cast to remind me of
that day and rub it in my face i'm gonna
go put an ad online so i can find
someone adopt this evil little turd
counterpoint you two make an adorable
couple might i suggest putting him in a
mug and pretending to take a sip oh my
god that cat is so cute
adrian are you living in the break room
busted my landlord kicked me out because
my stupid neighbors couldn't handle a
few tiny night screams
oh when i was undercover someone did try
and scalp me with a sharpened grapefruit
spoon sure that would do it aren't you
dating rosa can't you just stay with her
oh yeah no we're doing this really hot
thing where we haven't told each other
where we live
i will stay at your home thank you what
hannah you just said you wanted to help
oh unless
you weren't being serious which i would
get i've been betrayed before
get yourself some good earplugs because
i really downplayed how horrible those
night screams are all right i'll see you
later
nine nine will be hosting a bomb
defusing class tomorrow i highly
recommend attending diffusing an
explosive device is the ultimate test of
skill under pressure and the stakes life
or death will lunch be provided yes
conurson
anyone else
this class sounds like da bomb
i really you didn't attend if you're not
gonna take it seriously
yep dismissed
you don't cross-stitch for 20 years
without developing a steady hand 20
bucks says i do better in that class
than you do threadhead all right you're
on
if you wanted to insult me should have
called me a stitch skipper okay stitch
skipper oh i handed it to you
you better look cute in this picture and
no one's gonna want you
do something with your damn paws whoa
whoa sarge relax
look i think he might be overreacting a
little to this prank and i should that's
a great prank yeah you get a cat we're
getting somewhere but if you're having
dad problems that's my jam son real
weird take on my crappy father you know
how i turned the corner with my dad i
stood up to him and that's what you need
to do with your dad oh he died in 1988.
ah okay well that probably won't work
then yell at his tombstone
knock it over what are you talking about
terry you are a human mountain you have
more muscles in your ears than i have in
my entire body never skip ear dj
[Laughter]
i want that cutaway get on over the 6'5
and make those big jerks take back that
tiny kitten yeah all right i'm doing it
[Music]
didn't work
i have more kittens than before you
lucky guy
i love them
i want them i'll take
them good morning my sweet little cuties
don't call them cute they'd kill us all
if they were smart enough to use weapons
but you're not smart you're dumb you're
always naked and you pee in a box
the only thing those bullies have over
you is that you never solved that case
so why don't we solve it together how
are we gonna do that steal that old case
vial and work it until we find your
burglar then we march back into that
precinct and we grind these kittens up
and shove them down their throats
[Laughter]
i slept like a freaking baby last night
staying at chuck's is like a dream
little guy loves doting on me although
you're gonna need to buy some bigger
underwear if we're gonna be sharing you
know what i mean okay i'll get right on
that
okay how about luck gina game there's
someone's blood all over the bathroom he
sleep choked me twice and the worst part
this morning he ate all of my cereal
that's the worst part they were new at
flu scouts brands circles i had them
shipped from oslo oh i want him out
if you want to beat an alpha you have to
be an alpha rongo
if you're good enough at being a beta
then the alpha takes mercy on you and
ends up giving you what you want
some dude yarfed in the men's restroom
could you please find somebody to clean
that up
terry
there was no yarf
yeah i figured that out okay let's see
what we got here
that's a really hot cop damn
ids with cell phone detonators oh
is that c4
oh my we've got some great bombs today
people
[Music]
hey slowpoke when we get out of here i'm
gonna needlepoint you a pillow that says
kapow amy you suck
santiago diaz enough this is not about
who's fastest this is a bomb dismantling
class we are police officers not street
urchins playing speed chests in the park
for shane
ain't no jerry's game
she was either at our restaurant or the
movies or doing something else and she
was either alone or with people
climb out on that ledge and see how the
perp got in we're ten stories up you can
handle that i'm scared of bees i'm
scared of snakes and i'm scared that the
knicks might never be good again but i
am not scared of heights we're gonna die
we're gonna die we're gonna die
[Laughter]
sure maybe none of the work we did today
led to any new information and sure most
crimes are solved within the first 48
hours but they never talk about the
crimes that are solved within the first
100 million hours
the guy who inspected this elevator in
1996 was named zurb godanya that's the
same weird name who inspected the
elevators in all four of the buildings
we've been to today really
terry that's elite the club
international of brighton beach
international club
you didn't really think that you could
run an operation in the 6-5 without us
finding out did you you know what i hope
the guy in there is a cat that'll show
you yeah if he was a cat it'd be much
easier to apprehend and probably much
less dangerous that's what we think
let's go
i'm ready to try it your way shhh you
came at the perfect time he's eating and
when an animal eats that's when they're
at their most vulnerable
is this i need a wolf name yes might be
more protective
who's afraid of virginia woolf though
hey little man let's talk about how much
longer you're gonna state my place
are you threatening me chuck do we're
not sir i just want to tell you how
welcome you are to stay with me forever
and ever and ever the lord
the lord
don't be so weird about it as you wish
good day sir that's still weird
is he just eating peas
we both said hurtful things you didn't i
was fine well now you're just lying to
yourself
holt was right we should have taken this
more seriously ha ha
done fastest time today by a full two
minutes
is everything okay over here yes
couldn't be better because i destroyed
you both
i did say that so you would go slower
and i would win which is what happened
you're just as competitive as we are
absurd i'm more competitive
way to just gave him a covert signal now
he's getting up yeah and now he's
following said waiter to a secondary
most likely even shadier spot
something's going on in there huh yeah
right huh come on let's go bust oh no no
no no
no nypd
oh
what are you doing man nothing i high
cholesterol my wife says i cannot have
red meat so they sneak in my beef stew
please don't shoot oh
my god it happened again
oh
chair that's even more dumb
you're here terry moving closer so i get
you in the photo
maybe they'll send you free beef stew
though why are these dicks out of their
cage i stayed up all night working on
your case and hans john and nakatomi
made for great
ah nice let me show you what i did i
started off by making a map of all of
the burglaries that have gone down in
brooklyn since 1996 to see if there was
a pattern
that led me to this
check out his sneakers 95 jordans they
came out a year after the accident look
at the souls
they're all muddy which means that son
of a [ __ ] can walk
bingo
that's big
yeah
all failed apparently our instructor
felt we didn't take it seriously enough
but hitchcock and scully passed
what how did they defuse bombs better
than we did those were bombs
unbelievable
there is a precision driving class next
weekend
fastest one around the track wins it's
on i'm gonna run you both off the road
into a wall
i'm gonna kill you
oh why would you bring these to the dry
cleaner for me tell them the red stains
are blood and the brown stains are uh
let's say blood
it's time for you to get out of
charles's house today you don't tell me
what to do uh that's where you're wrong
baby girl i run this precinct watch this
skully
go to sleep okay
you're gonna get out of chucky's house
and what's more you're gonna pay him
rent for the night you spent there
fine one more thing babe you're gonna
thank us both right now
thank you
that was amazing told you he just needed
to be alfred is that what happened or
did i just beta you into protecting me
no
it's not what happened this is not your
victory
sure
oh my god
he's you i know
spirit animal charles
so this is weird
oh no you don't circumstance
i knew it you could walk the whole time
i was right about the catacombs too huh
now where's the cat been 20 years sarge
cat's probably dead i'm still bringing
him in
he's got a gacy picture hanging up of
his bed it just reminded me that i have
people in my life who cared about me i
don't know why i'm spending so much time
trying to prove things to people who
don't i guess you're a big man and more
ways than one
which i probably should have anticipated
but
did not oh no
the rats i couldn't wait enjoy the rats
you rat
oh my god
oh no one's coming for me
always take
the petty
way
if an opportunity presents itself and
you can justify it
take it
if you're in conversation and you're
like yeah i got my revenge so i put some
rats in their office because they've
been torturing me for two decades now
people be like yeah good for you yeah
all this high road [ __ ] how often are
you gonna have an opportunity to take a
take the petty way through it
two
why is jason manzukis only listed as a
guest star i know this is a problematic
territory for me uh-oh
three
the bomb stuff was funny it was good
bombing
and uh a plus bombing a plus bombing
nice reveal one on holt made sense with
the character
four
amy made me laugh a a couple of strong
strong times that i just remembered a
couple of comments i read in last week's
video they've haunted me to my god are
you
and i've
been up many nights you itchy about what
have i said you blasphemer i betrayed
the b99 you've betrayed the whole
precinct what have i done you're worse
than the six five
when i'm moving on we're on number 19.
no no no my number
five
number five i've been counting what i've
been pointing out oh yeah number five
five
gina's kind of hot it didn't hit me
until now oh yeah yeah yeah she puts on
that alpha mode like in uh
in full regalia and there you go i was
looking at she jordan peel's wife are
they still together i think so
nice
yeah
he didn't say nope to her nope
nobody told her to get out yet no
that's right
yeah we're the key
i don't have wonderlust when i'm with
you
he's in wanderlust
is he he's in the movie wanderlust in
fact you know why i know that
because in the greatest scene in any
movie ever where paul rudd's at the
mirror
the scene comes to an end when he is
interrupted by jordan peele god i don't
remember that so every youtube snippet
that has paul rudd in the mirror with
the whole the whole d monologue
it always cuts off right as uh jordan
people hey you okay man yeah yeah yeah
like she's not
been attracted to me all these years
something about that confidence and
assertiveness made me go damn i don't
know man i was getting pretty hot yeah
where are we on six six six
cats man cats love cats the cats were so
adorable my god kittens that's when
they're the most precious
watch them grow in [ __ ]
demanding [ __ ]
who expect so much of you guarantee you
there's two outside this door right now
who are like feed me i'm gonna be like
it's not time yet
but they expect it because they're bored
that's right they want to be outside
because i haven't had time to play with
them
seven
where do i know that guest star from
that douchebag cop oh uh that is matt i
think his last name is besser he's one
of the he's yeah he's
he pops up in a lot of comedies and he's
one of the founders of ucb i think oh
really yeah he's not peter boyle's son
i don't think so
but you never know
do you know who peter boyle is yeah he's
uh the dad and everybody loves raymond
and he was also a young frankenstein
have you seen everybody loves raymond
i've seen not comprehensively the whole
show but because of your recommendation
when we were lads i've seen a bunch of
episodes i would i would search it out
when i got home from school days
brilliant brilliant funny show
funny show i was the only person in my
family who watched it
so good
so good
eight
yeah dealing with alphas are tough
you just gotta get to a point where you
get so angry that you're just
irrationally yelling now
that's what you do you get so festered
up that now you're just you just
there's no healthy way to stand up you
just eventually gotta just start
exploding on them because it's all pent
up and then you look like the irrational
one who lost
that's how you handle alphas
by losing control of dominant people in
your lives
you just blow up on them
it's good i'll take that advice
nine john comes up with something nine
of euro greg also observed
that
uh that's not to be my observation okay
ninth observation about the episode uh
despite
you know the the abundance of hijinks i
thought there was a nice uh character
heartfelt core at
the center of each story you know what
i'm trying to say
so this was a well-rounded episode
you've had nine stages
to think about what to say and it took
you
you had to work 10
ten
a lot of great animal actors in this
episode
cats had to go through a lot of
emotional duress as terry berated them
mercilessly
i would have broke that man's spine
and then really paralyzed him yeah then
set back the entire case
11.
can you actually solve the case two
decades i feel like that is well beyond
the statute of limitations yeah
okay
i mean it probably wasn't an open case
anymore there's a cold case maybe yeah
the case went cold yeah starring armor
and greg
is that who was on gold games
i've seen some cold case in my day
that's right
you know maybe
12. john looks up cold case time yep
before we go to this event that i
definitely am way behind i gotta get
ready okay let's see cold case the show
cold case
i don't know i think 2003 history show i
don't think that's that's greg from
dartmouth catherine morris danny pino
jeremy rashford she's got nothing to do
with this show justin chambers john
finch what show was i thinking about
that had that
great guy
which crime series had
the dharma and greg guy dude here we go
dharma and greg
here what's the auto shoe or am i just
making that up all right we're gonna go
the other way with this we're going to
search criminal minds
oh people love criminal criminal minds
not cold case i haven't seen much i've
seen a little bit of criminal minds he's
got mandy patinkin and matthew gray
gubler as well yeah
256 episodes this guy did did you watch
dharma and greg you had to do that to
get over dharma yeah man you gotta go
look at the most
famous disgusting crimes in order to get
over her
anyway was a good show was darwin greg
good show guys i've never seen that
moment i like the episode a lot is a
good episode guys gina is gorgeous
we gotta do a shout out
eric courseman
he's funny he's funny two
he's loyal yes yes three three
he's an off-putting liberal
[Laughter]
four he's liberal
five five
he's got a real rejects tattoo does
absolutely six six were both
attracted to him
seven
he has a heart of booster gold he does
eight
this man
has
loyalty did i say that
you know what it bear's repeating even
if you did so rare quality
nine nine
he's a real peach because he's from
geological
and ten
he's got a big
[Music]